[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
I want to live because I don't understand
why
climate change political change
the  climate change political change
[Applause]
[Music]
you see
[Applause
] life
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
crouched
but no longer
d
[Music]
once
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
now
we have a future
[Applause]
save your throat
[Music]
hard
at the wheel
now
[Music]
ah
a
[Music]
hello
[Music]  ca]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
is an art
[Music]
in death
[Applause]
[Music]
the earth
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
animal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
d
him
[Applause]
[Music]
or not
the carbon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music
] death
ah
[Music]
yes  not
at all
yes
and yes
the Mayan land yes
[Music
] time
yes the
same I am
[Music]
d
[Applause]
and
[Music]
neighbor
and the land
I want to see you
[Music]
good
[Applause  ]
d
[Music]
[Applause]
and I said nothing
in culture
well
[Music]
[Applause]
the box and size
[Music]
at home don't say you're enough
[Applause]
[Music]
or not
ah
to improve it
[Music]
and we don't have dead services ok
the indications of your mind
slowly
[Music]
for a normal accompanist
the band is recorded
[Music]
d
yes no
[Music
] life
physically 56
[Music]
once
is that I already said it the chair
[Music]
but always
millions of young people in different parts
of the world take to the streets to make
a call for peace and we want
the war
that we humans have to end  we have declared to the
world
this is the time when we stop
being observers we become
activists
[Music]
ah
I want to say something
if they hadn't asked two hours ago there is
the angel and I half future
in twenty or thirty years
we haven't been  the future of my life
those who only seek
immediate economic stability but not sustainable
the beers that have not yet committed to
change have not guaranteed us one
however
now that we are
all here together
now that we can  I can see your faces full of
emotion and hope after this
international demonstration
I'm sure we managed to create an
impact on all the listeners they have a
special
[Music]
confirm a future for mexico
ah
commitment to rescue humanity
and the earth
requires many sacrifices but  without
a doubt
totally the penalties
and the companies are afraid of this
compromise of contempt for the words
of chalk if the solutions are
impossible to find in this system
the solution is also the system
e
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Applause]
we stopped
[Music] it
is the present and the future that we look forward to
what we say
1 like
[Music]
this afternoon
speaks mind
position
the climate of the planet any living thing
[Music]
how
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
and international
[Applause]
[Music]
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
the biggest problem the re  responsible for
time for survival
[Music]
ah
the competitor
and the president andrés manuel lópez
obrador to his cabinet and the congress of
the union is the following 1
we young people demand the right to live
in a healthy environment that is
protected by  a prosperous and
sustainable development that is to say that the short
article of the political constitution of
the United Mexican States is
respected as well as the final paris agreement
in general
and invest in projects
that comply with the three pillars of
sustainable development: social,
economic and environmental and
conventions washing
[Music]
this in order to
comply with a temperature of 15 degrees
in
point number 3 apply sanctions for
excess carbon emissions both
national and transnational public companies
[Applause]
of resource extraction in the solution process such
as fracking  the refining set
[Music]
[Applause]
for that
[Music]
the generation write  a better future
restores
withdrawn resources
[Applause]
the young students will choose the
present but they did not accompany today
[Music]
and
we must
not speak it is a period
[Music]
[Applause]
we do not want to leave this safe point
to keep them  and protect them from
generations
[Applause]
the tickets to the next
in yours they are the ones who
today will march with you for the future
for your future for our future
[Music]
[Applause]
d
good
[Applause  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
why
[Music]
no no
and
the last
[Music]
d
after
although the authorities
[Music]
how
[Applause]
[Music]
look
we all already found the song
in spaces enabled
adaptation
but I the truth
[Applause]
but let's say
the separation from life also
the actions
[Music]
well
with  30 people
[Music  ca]
[Music]
no
at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
the word
[Music]
[Applause]